allez les gars extraction d'une victime
accidenté les pompiers maîtrisent la
situation les gestes sont précis la
communication calme tout cela est un
exercice depuis six mois 14 compile
vinoy s'entraîne une fois par semaine
sur la prise en charge des victimes de
la route autour de différents scénarios
allez les gars on peut avoir donc deux
ou trois véhicules impliqués dans
l'accident on peut également avoir des
glissières de sécurité qui nous servent
d'obstacles des arbres des poteaux
téléphoniques
ça permet d'agrémenter les scénarios et
d'avoir toujours des choses à faire
plus complexe et et réfléchir à des
prises en charge
vraiment spécifique les exercices
doivent être réalisés en un temps
imparti 10 ou 30 minutes en fonction du
nombre de victimes afin d'assurer le bon
déroulement de la mission un chef
d'equipe chapeau de ses hommes sur le
scénario du jour les difficultés étaient
multiples c'est surtout la voiture qui
est en équilibre sur le capot avant
d'autres voitures
quoique et tombent des hacker faux
paquets tombe sur le personnel faut pas
qu'elle tombe sur la victime qui est à
l'intérieur et il faut pas qu'il ya sur
accident générés par le scénario mis en
place après chaque exercice les
sapeurs-pompiers débrief ni cohérent des
échanges constructifs pour se rendre
compte des erreurs ou salué
l'intervention
on a sorti la victime en moins de dix
minutes et l'objectif c'était dix
minutes on a sorti la victime en moins
de dix minutes en respectant les
consignes de sécurité en mettant en
application le matériel et
et tout le monde a bien oeuvré c'est
bien mais on va dire la pression pour ça
se passe dans de bonnes conditions
les hommes du feu pourront se mesurer à
d'autres pompiers français et
internationaux du 24 au 26 mai au
vélodrome national de saint quentin lors
des challenges nationaux
sapeurs-pompiers des compétitions de
désincarcération et de secours d'urgence
aux personnes seront organisées durant
ces trois jours